.
HIS MOTHER SAY
HIMSELF SHY BUT SN'T.
US, SH SO LIFE TGI
RAYMOND GREEN S FAMILY
YS HJUST LAND JOB AND COULDN'T W
GAS KINLF
TH ENTIRE LI AHEADF
HIM.
HE WAS A Q WITH HIS NGTIME GIRLR
PA INCLUNGLPED STOP THE RELY
SPOKE JU BAIR TIME.
I WANT TOUDISCUSSION, AND WHAT
HECRIBES I GRAPHIC AS
WHEN THE GUNN THE CLUB.
APPENED?
"NEW YORK TIMES" SAYING YOU WENT
INTO COMBAT MODE.
TS KICKED IN FROM
YON IRAQ AND
AFAN
>> FST I JUST
ABOUT ME.A
R E LOSS
HER BOYIEASFOX
RAA GREAT YOUNG MAN. O DAMAZING
THINGS, AND FOR ME RIGHTBOUT HE.
I HAVE WFRILL IN THE
HOSPITAL THAT WERE S
T S HERE.ORO S FAMI WHAT I TH
CTILY,  WT
AND  AAUD I
F  HT A LOT MORE.
NOT.
IT DSN
EITHER WAYI
GROUND S ROUNDS, I
N, PUSHED OVER M
ND W HIT THE GROUND, ME D
BAC--NDI FELL.
I FELL AGAINST THE --
SHOOTER.BENCH SEATING, AND SAW T
TO T PREECAUSEWHAT WAS GN.BUAP G
A LOT OF PPL
BUT I T OFEOTHIS GUY WAS THERE,
DOWN, AND THENO -- , E, I'M GETM
FOWITH HIM.
HIS RIFLE FLEW IN FRONT OF
JUMP IN E WITH ME, H WE
BOTH EITHER PULLED HIM DOW
HEND HEAD, RIGHT
NEXT TO THE D
TO HE  AY FROMM.HE AR.
N'S NAME.
AND THEN IO TAKE HISOTHEE PID T
WHERE I  THE IS ST
STARTE FOUND ATWEEN HIS ARMOR A
TARTEDAILING AWAY
WITH HIS GUN.AND THEN I TRONT
OF MHIG
HIM.
AND WAHIM DO. MODE. I DID -- WHT
FOR THDOT DN'T EVEN RETIRE BECA.
I LOST
I TRIED.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE --
THE COME HOME AND THIS
I
YOU, MAN,
TR KIL .
MY LITTLE GIRL WASN THERE.
RE SO SORRY FOR THE LOSS
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY HAVE GONE
TH FOR THE LOSHTER'S BOYFRIEND,
ORO S STL THERE, AND I CAN'T IMG
THND WRAR ASOR.U TRAINEO THAT
OUT FOR A NIGHT ON
THE TOWN.
>> YEAH, YOU
IFLLY DO THIST,
IT'S IN YOU.D TO BR.I DON'T LIKY
JOE, I'M JUST
NORMALUY
I
REACHED UP AND I DID WI
TO
AND HON'T CARE
D ABOUT EVER W
AROUND ME.CILY. I GOT DONE WITH
THE CIN, I WENT THE ROOM AND
AND THE ARMS TH  EYES, STAY WIT
AND I MOVEE
ULDN'T SEE HER ARM BECAUSE WAS I
SO HIS
SO THAEYIFTOAK.
THIS GIS WHOLE THING WAS A LOT.
MY DAUGHTER,
NER EXPERIENATN Y
IN THAT BUILDING
ACCORD, BUCAD TO.
Y DAUGHTER, FO IT WAS ALWAYS
GET IN THE NEXT PATROLGE
GET OVER IT.GET IN THE NEXT PAT.
NOE O GET ON THE
PATR.
AVE TO LE WITH THIS
KICKG ANOTHER HUMAN INHEI TOLD O
D
THERE WAS A BEAUTIFUL, OTHE PERG
WHEN THE KID WAS GETTING TIRED H
BECAUSE SHE'S  SCARED.T S GOIN
THERE.NG TO GET PEOPLE TO
CALL THE POLICE, AND THAT WAS
I'M JUST A GUY THAT ED TO
PROTECT DS AND WIFE, A I'TO PROI
OR, YOU LPF
PEOPLE.
WHAT YOUUR FAMILY  T
PE WEN.
T RAYMOND VANCE.T YOURYFRIEND.
HOW WILL YOU REMEMR HIM?
RE GOING THROUGH LOTMAN.
S 22.
BUT SHE LOVED  BEN WIT
O  HER JUNIOR
PROM DATE, LITTLE WY K WASINY
OTE IN 2007.
WYATT HAS BEEN WITH HER THE
WHOLE TIMER BEST
WERAG SHOW. AMAZINGND
THEN TPPENS, AND MY
DAUGHTER L HR BOYFRIEN'S BEEN
WITH FOREVER.MOM, WE WERE HERE U
HOW DO WT RAYMOND.
>> WRRY.
I E  RUBBINGR
SH TRE W
DOING?
>> THEY'RE HURTINGN.
THEY'RE HUINWET WE CAN.WE'RE N.O
TH THEM ON THE WAY HOME
FROM THEY DAUGHTER
BROKE KNI  FOR
THE THE OF US.
D  NIG,  M
BEHE EACH OWE BOTHOTHER WE'RE B
WHOLE TIME.LL GOT TO GET THIS
GU
WE G T HIMSO
HUD
[ BLEEP ]
HELY.N STRONGLO GOING TO BEFOLP
O TAKEARE OF
THROUGH THIS. IOWNG TO EVALND
OF PEOE. LPEOPLE, AND
DONE, AND I WANT TO THANK
YOIFVE
THEMS R ORE YOU GOI  WAN
APOPLE T
LL OF THEM DESERVE TO HEIR KI
GLHE'S
R RICHL THESEE E WITH THEAMILIE